as you remember from this video we built
the scale replica of my city and today
we're going to be playing hide and seek
across the entire city there is quite
literally tens of thousands of places
for these people to hide they can hide
in corners
on roofs in basements in trees in the
road wherever they want in the city this
video is going to take forever to film
i'll call my wife and tell her i'm not
coming home tonight we have to find a
hundred people across our entire city we
need help you're right chris which is
why we brought pippa the guy who oversaw
the building of this place and leave
hey man this place was huge and it took
a ton of time to build like if i go into
my time played
it says 2.5 days server they are all
hiding uh chris no looksy duxies pippin
leapy
everyone get in here we're in hurry
chandler
arm so when you see a building that
tickles your fancy for a hiding spot
just holler at me
9998 99999
10 000. i totally didn't count let's go
look all right let's go
before we completely flatten buildings
let's start by looking inside
wait who made this giant hole just
straight into the bottom oh
chris is right here chris is right there
who made this hole
chris what are these ulta snowballs do
so no more throwing a single snowball
for the rest of your life oh i see
chandler i see chandler he's in the
street
i see him i see him i'm getting inside
hey hey guys crouch crouch don't let him
see us
he's hiding behind a painting no
i found away from me
and chandler is dead deleted what am i
supposed to do now chandler i'm gonna
let you hide a second time this pink
building looks a little suspicious
let's search it from the ground up hey
jimmy i don't know where the door is so
let's just
yeah thank you thank you for making a
door oh whoa what's going on ah
what what i'm stuck you're not stuck
you're chris
no one was in the pink building boys
let's proceed to the next one you know
what we should do chris
after we search a building we should
level it
well if there was someone in there
there's not anymore we inadvertently
blew a hole in this building
wait let's see if you can see anyone
everything's just exploding still
this is insane the server is like what
did i do
what did i do to deserve this meanwhile
okay
yeah i don't like the way that building
looked at me it looks evil
it does let's go scan it preach preach
preach oh my god we're just doing that
that scared the poop out
oh no this building's made out of gravel
it's all uh
all right don't over beach don't over
beach dude i'm really not seeing people
maybe it's because it's quite literally
a freaking city chris yeah that's true
there's so many places to like hide i
don't know how we're supposed to pick
one
what is going on why are the blocks
you're going to
what is this they're like flying away
it's snowing
chris this map is huge i can't find
anyone
wait i bet you someone's behind this
staircase no minecraft steve
what are you guys wait so chris you
found astro fluff yes sir
what do you mean i don't see anyone oh
all right i'm gonna go back to my search
sir
you clear the other building yes yes
here you know what i don't feel like
going in this building
you're just gonna flatten it it's fine
oh someone's in it
oh someone's in it pika tails more like
pika
dead get you a bro that can finish your
sentence for you
oh i am the god of the map i will
obliterate it all
see this park right here what is this
see it yeah i feel like someone's in it
flyby i just i have a very strong
feeling someone's in here oh
oh there's his suspicion was correct oh
my gosh he looks like a little rabbit oh
he's running he's running
he doesn't want to die meanwhile stop
do you like this me across your face i i
guess you could
say we really wrecked this park get it
like parks and rec oh i get it so
anyways i feel like we've destroyed 30
buildings but literally most of the city
is still intact we still have 60 people
we have to find chris
also this place this looks suspicious i
bet someone's in here oh my gosh i
called it
it just looked like a suspicious
building like if i was a hider i would
have hid in here
oh poor guy he's got a cool skin yeah
what skin
oh it took a few hits oh i see a name
tag
i see a name tag oh chris sorry look at
this this looks like a nice little
starbucks can i get a vanilla bean
frappuccino with java
chips what size um what's the large one
venti chris i think it's time we take on
this
giant behemoth before we completely
demolish it let's you know let's search
it by hand why is there an x-wing
fighter inside
of a building i'm confused what x-wing
fighter okay it's gone
oh whoa
oh if i was someone hiding i'd
definitely hide here
oh my god this is the door floor dude
there's still quite a few more floors
chris holy crap this building is huge
no no i'll save you
can't breathe i can't breathe
help i guess we're gonna have to do cpr
all right chris you know what we have to
do what's that whip out your noose
all right nuke time anybody i say one
daddy goodbye
pippin sorry for all your work pippin
i didn't see anyone die but the player
count went down by three so
i guess there was actually people hiding
in there yeah so we really worked
hard on every single interior there is
an interior on this map for almost every
single building did you work hard on
this tree right here
maybe all right interesting oh so that
was the wrong
snowball bud who did that gentlemen this
is taking forever i say we splitsy
ditzies
wait a minute i feel like someone's
hiding in the spawn building
oh oh my gosh oh i heard something i
heard something
ah it was carl i told you how did you
know that
because carl chandler's here as well
all this stuff's all distractible
hold up hold up hold up carl's trying to
make a breakaway all right i'm going to
kill carl real quick so i can go back
and kill chandler
i'm burning i'm running
i'm running carl taylor's on fire they
see me man it's done
they're above me like some eagles oh my
gosh they're hawking me no he saw me
i really have to chris take over
what is what's going on what are you
guys doing are you guys
throwing a shirt why are you on strike
[Music]
chris what is this carl and chandler are
epic you guys got rid of my inventory
too
oh i feel bad jimmy i uh i may have
found someone in this pool you're
talking about
oh my gosh i didn't even know that was a
thing this is why we have leap and pip
and helping us search because i would
not have known this was the thing here's
the problem chris one has beast merch
and one doesn't which means the one
without beast merch much to die and the
one with beast merch
also has to die because the person last
time had beast merch on and i don't want
people to think i play favorites you
cannot be biased
40 players remain only one can win i see
quite a few name tags in this building i
think we just hit the jackpot all right
i'm going in nope i'm gonna blow it up
boom i'll kill people faster than you
can blow it up oh yeah you see those
name tags they're squirming
oh baby finally
i've literally been looking for what how
long has it been since i joined this
team
[Music]
yay i have a feeling someone came back
to the capitol building you want to just
level it yeah i'm re-leveling it
did you put this here yo this is like an
entire t-rex what
i'm walking through a school right now
but if i was hiding
i'd go over here i'd do the
loop-de-scruti and i'd hide
in this room
[Music]
these buildings were untouched untouched
no more
guy k2142 chris
do the honors all right sorry sir
sometimes chris i forget that all these
buildings literally exist in real life
like this
whatever this is this random building is
real are there this many parking garages
in raleigh
i just forget there's like a thousand
look the lego store is untouched
chandler stop throwing for a second
the lego store is untouched oh someone's
definitely in the bus someone's in the
bus
hold up hold up hold up reach reach
reach the bus is very small
wait he's just hiding in the cobwebs
he's hiding under the map everybody
give him a salute oh yeah he won't have
time to get out he won't have time to
get out
oh he didn't have time will he get away
will you do it
or just bomb him someone fell
let's go oh chris tp to me i just found
a school
okay this sounds ominous
i'm gonna end the sentence there oh i
see someone i see someone
i don't know i see someone i see someone
get him get him bravo six going dark
no no guys guys guys he's shaking his
head no just don't look great guys you
you really far away yeah put your hands
on your ears yeah okay
all right okay you can you can look down
okay
did he go to a farm like my parents told
me he went to the farm yes
are you crazy with the farmers you look
like you're crying did that hurt i did
hurt i'm so sorry
yeah that's what happens when you get
found
yeah we have a problem what is it our
city is way bigger than i thought it was
this is taking forever so what i did is
i sectioned off this one
big building right here i'm going to tp
everyone to me and give them another
minute to hide in this building and then
we're going to manually search this
building using no snowballs
no explosives until someone wins okay
everyone face this way
we're gonna wait a minute and then we're
gonna go search the final building
and whoever we find last gets tense
macaroni let's go
20 people left remember you guys decide
who here makes 10 grand and who does not
make 10 grand all right let's make a
decision right now this guy doesn't
uh oh sorry buddy i found someone on the
perimeter
goodbye oh chandler you missed this guy
got him
i found someone there's a hidden tunnel
here carl carl come here by the way 10
people are left
only 10 remain carl come over here all
right i'm going over here
how did these guys get in here oh
there's a hole oh no sorry bud
six remain cookie oh i found someone
else in the maze
come back here come back here
got him wait so two people remain
whoever you find next
doesn't get 10 grand
oh my gosh this i found zakrov wait
really
yeah dude he was blending in with the
wall bro he was blending in with the
wall oh my god
man that kind of deserves to win 10
grand but not really
lucas the person did one congratulations
you win you just won 10 000
pause this guy actually won the ten
thousand dollars during the setup of
this sudden death here we accidentally
made an error basically due to an error
from our admin team this guy was
actually found earlier in the video and
already killed but somehow he was still
entered into the sudden death which was
100 our fault he did nothing wrong i do
apologize for how confusing this is
the actual first place winner received
ten thousand dollars and the second
place winner got three thousand five
hundred dollars just because we felt bad
we want everyone that competes in our
competitions happy but more importantly
than anything we want our competitions
fair thank you so much for watching hit
subscribe we'll see you guys later